So meta reasoning can be very difficult
to talk about because it's circular.
So it's often unclear what exactly
we're talking about at a given time.
So to try to make this process more
explicit, let's take an example.
Let's imagine a robot whose task is
to assemble a camera, and all day,
every day, the robot sits there
assembling camera after camera.
Then one day, the boss walks in and
says instead of assembling that camera
disassemble this camera,
it's already been put together.
So what does the robot do?
It wasn't programmed to
disassemble cameras.
So how does it figure
out how to do this task?
Well, the robot might have a rule,
that says given a new goal or
given a new problem.
Choose the method for
which I have the most knowledge.
The robot might then look at its
memory and say, well, the only thing
I have is a bunch of cases of assembling
camera after camera, after camera.
So this is Metacognition, the robot has
now thought about it what it knows,
it's thought about its new goal, and
it's decided on a method to use
to approach this new problem.
But now that the robot has selected a
method, it then needs to reason further.
Its chosen case based reasoning
of its reasoning method.
But how will it do the adaptation?
Well, the robot might then select
a rule out of its memory, it says,
to reverse the process
do the steps in reverse.
So now we've done,
not only strategy selection,
when we select a case based reasoning,
but we've done strategy integration.
It is now using a rule based approach,
to take care of the case adaptation.
So, the robot uses that rule, reverses
the steps, and dissembles the camera.
Now the boss comes back by and says,
well, yeah, you disassembled the camera,
but why did it take so long?
You could have done it so much faster.
But the boss doesn't give
any feedback as to how,
the robot could have done it faster.
Then later,
the boss brings back another camera and
says here, disassemble this camera,
but do it faster this time.
So now the robot needs to
select a method again.
It thinks, last time, I used case-based
reasoning to select my method for
disassembling the camera.
But case-based reasoning didn't
give me an optimal solution,
the boss complained it took me too long.
So instead, the robot chunks a rule that
says, given a new task of disassembling
a camera, suggest strategies
other than case-based reasoning.
So now,
it's used a form of meta Metacognition,
it's thought about its Metacognition.
It's looked at the way it selected
a strategy in the past and
decided the way I selected a strategy
in the past must not have worked,
because the strategy I
selected wasn't ideal.
So next time select
a different strategy.
So here we've seen everything we've
talked about today in action.
First, we saw using
Metacognition to resolve a gap.
The agent didn't have any way
of disassembling a camera so
used to select a strategy for
resolving that gap.
That's also strategy selection,
it use case-based reasoning
to decide what method it should
use to resolve this gap.
We then saw strategy integration where
we use the rule-based approach to adapt
its prior cases.
We didn't thought correcting mistakes
where the boss told the robot they
didn't do it fast enough, so
its reasoning method must
have been suboptimal.
So next time if you try
something different.
Now, last part is also an example
of Meta Metacognition or
metacognition about Metacognition.
It looked at the strategy selection
method and decided next time,
I should select a strategy differently.
>> David's example of a robot that knows
how to assemble cameras but then is
given the goal of disassembling a camera
is a good example of goal base autonomy.
Earlier we had looked at, how an agent
can go about repairing this knowledge
a reasonable or learning when it
makes a mistake or reaches a failure.
But sometimes it is not so much that
agent reaches a failure as much as it
is that it is given a new goal.
When the agent is given a new goal,
we do not want the agent to just fall
apart, we do not want brittle agents.
We want agents that can then
adapt their reasoning methods and
their learning methods to
try to achieve the new goal.
Even if they were not necessarily
programmed to achieve that goal for the.
We know that human cognition
is really robust and flexible.
You and
I address a very large number of task,
a very large number of problems and
achieve a very large number of goals.
If you had to design human level,
human like AI agents and
those AI agents will have to be
equally robust and flexible.
Metacognition provides a powerful
way of achieving that robustness and
flexibility.
It does so, by flexibly, dynamically
selecting among competing strategies.
It does so, by flexibility and
dynamically integrating multiple
strategies as a problem solving evolves.
It does so,
by using reasoning strategies and
knowledge that were programmed
into it to achieve new goals